well good day to you and a greeting to
you for the second time today this is a
great session I really enjoyed the
session with folks on the other side of
the globe and I think some very
interesting elements were introduced in
our own discussion it was very very
beneficial in a sense we kind of know
where we each of us stand there's
another group that comes and introduces
number of issues that were quite
significant so let's hope that we can
maybe do it now it will be good let let
me as as it is customary make few
introductory comments about the theme
that we have and then other people who
are part of this class will continue we
are shifting from this morning session
which was on religion and violence and
building on the session previous
Thursday again on religion and violence
to religion and or faith and
reconciliation and the two of course can
be quite kept apart they bleed into into
one another so I thought I'd make just a
few introductory comments first about
kind of discrepancy that one can see and
on the one hand in the public
imagination fades are seen as
predominantly violent but in the self
perception of religious people religion
or faiths are seen as predominantly
peace promoting now the possible
explanations for this if I'm right about
this one is kind of a rosy
self-perceptions perception all faiths
are violent somebody might argue but
like most people religious folks like to
think of themselves well as well as of
their kin and so they have an image of
themselves as being peace promoting or
it could be the case of a kind of a
skewed public imagination fates are on
the whole piece promoting but here we go
where's the media person but media by
their very nature zero in on break down
non-violence and create an image of
faith as predominantly violent as a
possible imagine maybe the both of these
are the case both Rosie self-perception
they're indicators that fates are more
implicated in violence that adherence of
a particular faith want to admit and
also skewed public perception there are
indicators that fades are less violent
than it appears from the presentation
public presentation of those faiths but
there's an element which i think is
significant in this perception of faith
in conjunction between faith and
violence and that I think is the
character of peace making itself I think
promoting peace is an activity which
inherently entails simultaneous pursuit
of two goals and not just 11 of these
goals is quite an obvious one and that's
maintaining harmonious establishing or
maintaining harmonious relations with
other individuals and communities and
for that you need something like a
compromise and therefore flexibility in
terms of boundary maintenance ability to
adjust one's own identity and encounter
with the other sometimes that those
compromises in Taylor laws and if the
peace process goes well they are kind of
win-win compromises and it also in
addition to this compromise involves
something like commitment to Mercy
willingness to forego full-scale
retribution and without such compromise
and such mercy there could be or would
be difficult to achieve peace when I
talk about these issues sometimes I tell
a story which I am told is rabbinic and
when I tell that story is Rebennack
there's a bit of a debate that ensues
whether it is remedy or not I got it
from philadelphia inquirer oliver and so
simply right exactly in philadelphia
inquirer there was a story about a
rabbi's rabbinic story right we'd said
that when God was creating the world are
the the all-knowing one saw what human
beings with kinds of propensity that
they have will do to one another and
then
the old just one decided if they were to
do that I will have to punish them and
if I punish them they will lose their
life that way I would destroy them and
so the all-merciful one decided to
forgive the world before he could create
it right so that in a sense of
forgiveness in this account goes into
the very structure of the possibility of
there being something like harmonious
existence at all certainly harmonious
one so these are these are kind of
elements of a the philadelphia inquirer
and yes hi bra i made amazing things
because you can find you can find there
and I think severe profound rabbinic
were being story but but the
significance of of Mercy significance of
forgiveness for interpersonal relations
indeed for social well-being social
existence itself but in peacemaking
these are kind of to all the obvious
things in terms of peacemaking but
there's something let some some less
obvious goals of peacemaking and that is
I think maintaining integrity of a self
and of a community protection of
boundaries of a cell for community
precisely when they're understood is
flexible is essential because otherwise
flexibility male may entail precisely
the loss of one's own identity and also
I think connected with that commitment
to justice without maintaining
boundaries and without securing justice
whatever justice here means there could
mean no peace but you could only have
something like pacification and it's
precisely because it's essential element
of a peace building process to have
concern for integrity or communities and
for justice that sometimes faith
precisely when they promote peace may
also appear indeed have to act in a way
that pushes back and they appear then as
being possibly a violent I think it's
essential to promote both of these
harmonious relationships as well as
concern for integrity of self and
community and these two goals our
intention
with one another and often give
different perceptions depending on what
you think is just and what you think is
appropriate boundary now let me mention
just in a few words elements of
peacemaking that religions can
contributes faiths can contribute and
these come from our discussions that we
have had here in sections and they come
also from the readings that we have had
one element that we have mentioned is
the character or one aspect that needs
to be mentioned is the character of
faith itself last week I talked about
the relationship between thick faith
versus thin fate professor Blair has
earlier spoken about lived faith or
spirituality as distinct from faith as a
mere cultural resource and you've seen a
number of our readings that we've had
whether that Serbia whether that Sri
Lanka and now in the case of Ireland
that some such distinction can be i
think useful we may also in our readings
we've encountered distinction between
people of faith as agents and religious
institutions and how they how they act
and that may be important thing to keep
in mind and differences of sensibilities
of these two sets of sets of actors and
that may be really important for us to
think about because in modernity under
the conditions of modernity and within
the context of globalization there is
happening clearly a secularization in
the first and original sense of that
term namely differentiation of spheres
so that religion gets to be decoupled
from spheres of economy spheres of
government other also spheres but that
creates a possibility I think of
religions being engaged without
necessarily feeding into into kind of
stable national identities and promoting
violence instead of promoting a piece so
the under context of globalization under
context of modernity I think peace
promoting character of faiths can be I
think better a better engaged in then
let me just
few words about the forms of engagement
and the basically what we what we saw in
the readings was a kind of
transformation of attitudes and
sensibilities on the part of the fades
as preparing the ground for peacemaking
shaping you can put it this way fades
contribute to shaping of a peaceable
self a peaceable individual who wants to
engage in peace how do they do that well
here's some random random things faith
may be able to do that by the fact that
they don't define a self primarily by
ethnic and national belonging but rather
define the self primarily by broader
belonging transcending particular
loyalties of a group and if the self is
completely immersed into a group that is
in conflict then of course self always
has known individual has no ability to
distance himself from those conflicting
situations and engage in peace making
second humanizing the the enemy now in
the contrast to dehumanization which
often precedes violence and we have been
familiar with this kind of dis fanuc
forms of speech there are cockroaches
they're vermin they have to be
exterminated that kind of proceeds
violence that occurs has done preceded
in Serbia it has preceded in Ronda and
so forth in contrast to that I think
fates have the ability to emphasize that
every person is a creature of God so
human solidarity across group boundaries
third transcendence of narrow
self-interest and working toward common
good that is one of the features of
fades kind of stable features of it
takes one out of oneself to a larger
good including a common good some phase
at least making possible recognition of
error and wrongdoing without immediate
fear of legal persecution something like
what ray it's called repentance I can
distance myself from what I have done
and there's a space within the faith
which isn't in some other other other
spheres of life for something like that
to happen that opens the possibility i
think for reconciliation emphasizing
generosity beneficence forgiveness
compassion mercy compassion Buddhism
mercy in Islam and so forth and then
also giving those with whom one differs
even on very vital questions the Bennet
Eve benefit of the doubt that was from
our readings on Islam and peace making
this is the kind of critical tolerance
born out of compassion in Buddhist
tradition or Christians would sometimes
call that hermeneutics of charity
reading the other possibly in the best
light until proven otherwise and then
finally maybe it's important to note
that fates can generate hope often
reconciliation processes are processes
with very uncertain results with very
many obstacles and in order to embark
upon this uncertain journey one has to
be carried by kind of a robust strong
hope that reconciliation indeed is
possible and that often religious faith
our fates are able to provide and so if
you have this kind of social agents that
are shaped by faith traditions a
critical mask and emergen that can
prepare a road for reconciliation
process I think I will end here and pass
on the baton to Professor Blair and
the the role of religion in both
producing conflict or and being part of
a complaint and then how region can help
resolve conflict is is obviously where
we were most intimately concerned in the
northern Allen
but one of the reasons I was keen to
come to Yale was because of the book the
miroslav wrote which actually was an
explanation from the point of view of
someone living out in the Balkans next
week i go to Rwanda where again there
are tensions there and obviously when
I'm out in the in the Middle East you
see it very clearly there too now you
know we were debating a little bit about
this I think earlier today which is you
know are these conflicts truly religious
right some people say look they're not
truly religious it's that what they
really are is political or social or
economic and it's just religion gets put
in the mix somehow and to which my
responses I think there is an
interesting question as the degree to
which you can separate out the religious
from the political the economic and the
social but whether you like it or not
for whatever reason religion is there
and so it's not you know if you're
standing on either side of the divide in
in Jerusalem and I my office is actually
literally sort of yards on the into the
Palestinian side you know you would only
have to take a chair out in the balcony
and watch the passing traffic to see to
religious cultures going by not just two
groups of people so for whatever reason
it's happened like that is happened like
that and exactly the same of course was
was the case in Northern Ireland where
there was a difference interfaith not
into vapor in travail that she would in
a fake now the two gentlemen here that I
am extremely grateful to for having come
and here to share their experience with
with the class are actually people who
in the Northern Ireland peace process
are very well known in their own
in their own right father Alec Reed
played a very very important part in
bringing republicanism to the point to
which it could it could actually
understand sufficiently not just the
need for peace but how to achieve it and
Alec went through some very difficult
very difficult times in himself right in
the middle of that process I did I seem
to remember that there was a famous die
think of Time magazine front cover was a
Time magazine that you were yeah that
where he was on the front cover giving
actually I think the last rites to two
young people have been killed in the who
died that's right they pitted that these
are the guys who appeared at the they
lost their way they appeared at the
funeral of an IRA guy they were they
were off-duty soldiers family and
they're trying to get away and then they
were stopped yeah and then they were
deliver stuff they were shot and as they
lay dying he gave them the last rites
and then the Reverend Harold good who's
someone from the Protestant side but who
over many many years was critical to
bringing unionism Protestantism I think
I don't know how we describe it but into
the mainstream of the of the political
debate and then finally actually able to
see its way to an accommodation and to
peaceful coexistence with their Catholic
neighbors and that Harold also went
through really really difficult times I
mean perhaps 12 things they might
actually tell you about is what it was
like living in the middle of such a
religious conflict where the hatreds
became so intense and deep and the
greatest compliment I can play either of
these two people was that occasionally
during the course of the peace process
where we had two very tricky and
difficult things to negotiate about and
the question would it would arise is
there anybody who can you can bring in
who is objective but from the other you
know from the other side as it were
there two names came up more frequently
than anyone elses and if they were
chosen it was because they were
objective and if they weren't chosen it
was because they were objective hell I
remember I've never told you this you
guys were there are examples of the
latter as well as performer and so you
know it they can tell you a little bit
about that we could throw them
discussion just what it was like in this
situation but here's is here's what what
the two aspects where I think religious
faith come very important first of all
as I say for whatever reason religion is
there an important part of the complete
and so you know you can go about forever
about why but it's there and it becomes
a means of your identity you know that
is your badge that is your tribe almost
it's it becomes almost tribal and and a
whole culture grows up around it so you
know we the the the music the literature
the way of speaking the way of thinking
is also expressed in that religious
divide so the religion is is there and
they're very powerfully as a means of
identification and identification
in a sense in essence and distinction to
the other but the other way that
religion is important is that because of
that it's also important as part of the
solution so the people like Harold Malik
who were able to and willing to reach
out across the divide helped bring about
the circumstances in which culturally
again people began to feel maybe
peaceful coexistence was possible maybe
they could they could actually share
certain things maybe the device when so
vast and and and unbridgeable as as
people thought and then there was a
final point which miroslav touched on I
think was in the applebees stuff as well
in your reading that it's also the case
that faith precisely because it's based
on an overwhelming sense in the end of
hope and redemption and forgiveness and
and values that are transcendent in
their nature precisely because of that
faith properly express and properly
followed can show people the what
appears impossible is actually possible
so that also was an important aspect an
important role that the faith that faith
played so you know what what we're
trying to do here I think is to divide
the degree to which these issues are
truly religious or not but they should
to be de janeiro important to the
particular dispute secondly what is the
role that people come
play in the resolution of the scoop from
the different parts of the faith
community and certainly I think how
those transcendent aspects of faith and
overwhelm and defeat at the end those
aspects of faith than are based on
narrow doctrine defining difference me
as opposed to you so i think that's
that's all i really need to say by way
of introduction and actually you know
what i thought just a reflection
standing on the conversation we had with
the singapore students this morning
thank you guys for all getting up so so
early if it any of you bet flagging now
in the afternoon you know you've
probably never been up that long and
this time of the day but i thought what
was really interesting with the
singapore students is that they some of
the some of the phrases were different
but actually once you understood what
they meant they were talking about very
very similar things to the things we're
talking about here which i thought was
it's kind of interesting so we're going
to hear now from heroin from le we can
just get very quick little introductions
and then we're going to have a
discussion but these are two guys i mean
i just came in as a political leader and
tried to do my best to sort it they
lived they lived it are you going to
start off how early yeah yeah okay yeah
and they you sit here you guys what a me
yep so now we'll get it where we can put
some additional chairs or you want to
stay there or i will say that i will sit
at the side power they're sitting at the
same way and then holla can come
actually colleagues yeah here we go
further on it might you want to yeah one
one or the other please collection
you can okay take you out here got see
ya clock of the back wall there because
both father Alec and I come from
preaching orders yeah I kneel yeah I'm
hard to deal with you yes what point you
got out and when you're falling asleep I
want you alert first Neely's gonna help
you and he doesn't succeed I will so
he's starting the clock whose I did can
I say on behalf of both of us they thank
you very much indeed for this invitation
and this opportunity and this privilege
to be able to have this connection with
Tony Blair is is important to us because
it gives me an opportunity to say very
publicly to you and perhaps through you
to others are much indebted we are to
him for his intensely personal
contribution to our peace process and
the day literally the days and nights I
don't know what time he had you up this
morning but he wouldn't let the people
in Northern Ireland go to bed until they
had actually got this good friday
agreement signed an unsealed and so I do
want to say thank you to your indeed for
something way beyond the call of any
duty of any prime minister the other
thing ought to say is that the world has
been exceedingly generous to us in
Northern Ireland both in patients and
in-kind not least the United States and
the way in which it was generous to us
the time it was given by Bill Clinton
and the gift of Senator George Mitchell
all of these were hugely important gifts
to us because not only were they things
that we needed but there were signs and
symbols of the goodwill and they
the eager desire of the rest of the
world to see this little island which is
infinitesimally more globe sort its
problems and if we have any way of
giving anything back in return it is
very simply to share our story we cannot
tell people in other parts of the world
how to solve their problems that would
be improper and impertinent but we can
we can share our story and people are
now coming from different parts of the
world to visit us and inviting us to
other places to tell our story not to
say this is a blueprint for everybody
everywhere else but if there are some
lessons to be learned out of our
situation then we we share our story in
that spirit some of the things I was
going to say already being touched on
such as they is it a religious problem
in Northern Ireland or is it not a
religious problem and of course we've
got a good answer a good Irish answer to
that as we have to every question yes
and no it isn't it isn't to understand
in what way it is religious or not
religious you need to think of the
history and you've been doing some
reading about that and you know that
it's a familiar story of a settler
people on an indigenous Native people
the setter people who came from Scotland
and from England and were therefore
largely Protestant and a native
indigenous community who were Roman
Catholic it's a familiar story in this
this American continent it's a flume
your story and South Africa remoter
parts of the world the the Protestant
people having come from what we call the
other island of Britain they wanted to
and would still want to retain their
membership of the United Kingdom the
nationalist native indigenous people
would want to have total independence
for the for the island as a whole so
you've got the nationalist date of
indigenous people who are Roman Catholic
and the set
people who were Protestant and so you
get this immediate confusion between
Catholic and Protestant and they become
become labels for two different
communities of people sharing the one
piece of land and so cultured you could
argue it it's more to do with culture
than it is to do with Creed you could
argue it's more to do with territory
than it is with theology but that
doesn't mean we can just wash your hands
and say it's not really religious
problem we've nothing we can't take any
responsibility for it those of us within
the churches we must because even by our
identification with the aspirations of
both parts of this community we become
part of the problem and as priests and
pastors we are charged with
responsibility of ministering to those
who are part of our culture and part of
our community and inevitably and because
we are born within that we we grew up
with in it were nurtured in it therefore
we become a part of it the difficulty of
that is that if we allow that
identification and these political
aspirations to become the dominant
things within our lives then our faith
takes a secondary place and we become
unfree to be the reconciler that I
believe we within a judeo-christian
tradition are called to be we become
unfree if we become so identified and
sadly there are many examples of that I
have somewhere in my files something I
picked up and I was studying in the
States and it was something like 10
tests for healthy religion and they're
actually very simple I I was trying to
remember them as we were coming over and
it says asks very fundamental questions
like does a particular form of religion
build trust or fear does it build
bridges or walls
does it nurture love or hate is it an
instrument of healing or of hurt does it
build up or put down is it prophetic or
is it silent does it get angry and
justice or is it in different and those
are just some of the things I remember
the ways of testing whether your faith
is actually a constructive positive part
of life and contributor to society and I
would have to say that we wouldn't score
very highly on all of those questions we
might score a reasonably well on some of
them but taking them as a whole thing so
the institutions of churches
institutions are are difficult whatever
kind of institution to bring all your
constituents with you and so at the end
of the day a great deal of what we must
do to be reconciling healing people in
our society and we want to put our faith
to work yes we can look to the
institutions for statements and for this
and that and the other but the end of
the day it is the people of faith who
will be the healers in our society and
within our community I always argue that
what has kept us from going over the
edge has been a huge network of people
who were very committed to making sure
this was not going to destroy us and to
take their faith on a very personal
level and to try and make that their
contribution as distinct from that of
the institution and there are some very
remarkable stories about that which I
think are important that leads me to
hand over to Alec because I think one of
the one of the nicest tributes that has
been paid to you Alec was paid by Olivia
O'Leary a BBC journalist who in a
profile on Alec on bbc4
I said in every war there is a no man's
land into which very few people are
prepared to go Alec Reed was one such
person and I another image I have is of
stage curtains on the stage when you go
to theater the curtains are closed and
you wait for the great moment when
curtains are pulled back and there the
action begins but for that to happen the
house had to be a whole army of people
adjusting the lighting to bring it in to
light up the darker corners moving the
furniture to accommodate people so that
everybody will feel comfortable where
they are and at times helping to rewrite
the scripts so that they can be heard by
one or the other then the curtain is
pulled and you think not of the people
who move the furniture or readjust the
lights or helped with the scripts what
matters is what you now see I want us to
follow and that I think is the kind of
rule of many many people have played and
which has been our privilege to be a
part of so Alec the man who wandered
into the no-man's land for very few
people are prepared to go your turn well
and let me begin by saying that I am
more than 50 years old and I have been
more than 43 years in Belfast which I
believe I should be wearing medals but
anyway one of the problems when your
when your when your life is going but
like that is that to the disks in your
back get a bit worn with the result that
you get pain severe pains in your eye in
my case in my right leg but result you
have to take painkillers where the
result that my superior to give me for
painkillers before I started I never
took them before but again before I
believe
leave their pain killers with what the
result is but the point I want to make
is that your head starts to go around
the beers and it goes in and out
mountain in you know and it doesn't
function to to clearly so if I not don't
appear to be quite on the ball or quite
focused you know that it's the
painkillers well I would also like to
see now before I begin I would like to
just echo what harles that they're about
to Tony I should mr. and supposing
falling Tony layer now but he was for
ten years the Prime Minister of Great
Great Britain of the United Kingdom
which is no it's like you had to cv you
know and you were going for a job you
know they were say you were ten years
Prime Minister of the United Kingdom you
know too many people in the world you
can say that I'm kind of saying you know
but anyway that I mean he did play a
crucial role really in his whole kind of
openness and his willingness to kind of
try to understand the Republicans and
try to understand people who are trying
to negotiate with them and you see if
you if you are and I just say this very
briefly if you ever had to negotiate
with the IRA and try to get them to stop
which would be a primary objective you
use various arguments but one argument
you would use if you had a prime
minister like I shall I call informally
Mr Blair Tony and what would be a very
powerful argument you would say well now
we have a prime minister here who is
very flexible and as a matter of fact as
far as i know one of his grandparents
came from Donegal in Ireland and
therefore he has a certain understanding
etc etc then you reduce that argument
and therefore now while he is that he's
got the power let's let's move do you
understand so it's very important ever
to have somebody like him who was so
understanding so flexible so willing to
try and understand everybody's point of
view that if you were trying to deal
with with
paramilitaries are terrorists or
everyone to call them the factory to
report the fact we were able to say well
look at the Prime Minister we have is
very flexible he's understanding now is
the time for us to move them to make an
agreement or whatever so I would like to
us to pay that tribute to me he was a
very big he introduced a whole new
dimension to the whole Irish English
relationship which wasn't there for
example in Margaret atras time you know
so we shall ensure it Irish historians
when they write the history will give
him a special place as he deserves than
they do the contribution he made to the
piece we now have and we have a very
good peace in Ireland now actually and
there is a book which was published
recently called how the piece was one
and there's a photograph of them Martin
McGuinness who add lettuce allegedly at
least was a former chief of staff of the
IRA and on the other side is mr. Paisley
it was the leader of the right-wing
unionists and the two of them was
sharing of Jupiter I'll withdraw them
were laughing together so I think that's
kind of symbolic came of the situation
we have now where you're having well
where you have indeed at the moment you
have them Martin McGuinness as I say
very IRA Patterson and you're Peter
Robinson very right-wing unionist
extreme right you and mr. two of them
are beginning to run Arlen Arlen
together well this is a miracle I mean
we are I I attributed the prayers of the
people but i also think when history is
told it will be attributed to mr. Blair
here to his whole understanding his
willingness to try and be flexible and
to find support people who are trying to
do something even with the IRA I mean I
just like to paint activity he will go
down in Irish history and certain was
one of the crucial people who helped the
Irish to eventually make peace both with
a English and with among themselves now
i am very briefly idea how I personally
got involved somebody said to me say how
you got involved well and I live
clonard monastery in west Belfast the
Redemptorist monastery and in the 70s
and especially that time we had a
practice of going anytime anybody was
killed as a result of the troubles we
used to go to the funerals and one night
I was at a funeral and it was I can
remember during the way now I this was
of a nationalist man nationals man who
had been assassinated you like to use
that word by by loyalists paramilitaries
and I don't know whether anyway we were
saying the rosary as we do it Catholic
wakes and there was this woman a young
woman who was kind of leaning over the
coffin and she was going through most
heartrending Queen as they say in Irish
you know wailing and wailing and
claiming cinema center something wrong
in a country where people have to go to
that kind of suffering I mean this is
real agony she was expressing so I was
saying something should be done about
this we shouldn't be living in a country
where people have to go through this and
that was kind of the occasion that was
the experience which kind of prompted me
to start seeing what could be done about
stopping this kind of suffering and now
if you started to look at that the first
thing you know you came down to was that
you were trying other words you're
trying to prevent people being killed
and injured that's we're trying to do
and to prevent them stop them in during
this kind of heart brain so then from
our point of view that meant the IRA
because they were the people on our side
of the conflict on our community that
were causing death and destruction and
heartbreak and everything back though
they were killing people and but blowing
people up and that so it mentor we
wanted to stop this we had to go to the
IRA and try and persuade them to stop
and that's really was our role was to
stop people being killed and injured and
getting heartbroken because of IRA
activities so and that's how if you like
it was that experience that night when I
heard this woman the state of agony she
was in because her husband or I may have
been her son had been killed by
loyalists that I decided to get involved
and the strange kind of a thing then
without going on and I'm only going to
spit I mean if you go to if you engage
people like the IRA or I had the same
experience in the over in Spain with
Etta if you engage them in other words
actually I prepared to talk to them
listen to them they immediately respect
you for your willingness to try and
understand this question I've always
wondered this because you were the first
person to go low and do this with the
IRA what's the fact that you were a
Catholic priest important and I wouldn't
think so I wouldn't think so fact I was
a Catholic priests know of a Protestant
we hardly gone to them I'd say it would
admit the reception the important thing
pretend you don't think that I do I
think that they're the fact that
somebody was but maybe diff I suppose
now they feel more at home was a priest
of course and i think the feel more at
home with a priest and they would now
there be a bit more an interesting thing
was that way back in nineteen seventy so
he was it three there was a group of
protestant church man who went to meet
with David Colonel on the leadership of
the IRA in a two-place dining i declare
fecal kaity claire and they had arranged
this with them and the Roberta spent
three days together in this hotel and
unfortunately somebody tipped off the
Garda shaqada they are each please and
they came to raid the hotel the funny
story is that David O'Connell who then
was they the chief of the IRA was racing
down the stairs to get out before they
please came he said you'll find them
upstairs and they reached pass them up
the stairs and I find six
Protestant clergy said I got the large
upstairs I've missed the man that they'd
come to find but as a result of that
actually there was a early kind of
Christmas a Christmas ceasefire as a
result of that so they were actually
prepared to talk and listen to people
under great pity is that that was
interrupted because who knows what might
have happened of that meeting had been
allowed to continue but it was a an
interesting bit of our history but I
think that a Catholic priest obviously
had a hearing he wasn't coming in to
sort of pontificate from right side and
I think the pastoral side the pastoral
side of a priest because these people
would go these IRA people yes we would
go to Mass yeah well basically because I
heard this woman the Queen and the
wailing of this woman that knife and I
said something has to be done and since
the IRA were the people in our own
community who were causing death and
destruction and heartbreak I said we're
gonna have to go to the IRA and I was
surprised when it went to the IRA that
they were quite positive in their
willingness to take a peaceful approach
I remember going to a colleague and
saying look we're pushing an open door
here and that was interesting in other
words my first encounter with the IRA to
try and persuade them to go peaceful I
came we instead we're pushing an open
door I picked up immediately that there
would be more than willing to go
peaceful if there was a peaceful way now
I've also experience of dealing with
Etta in in the past situation and the
first time I met them we met over a meal
see if you the fact that a priest or
somebody like me tries to help me easily
gains their respect they respect you for
that many of their respect you they will
cooperate with you well I'm just saying
that when my dealing with both the two
those two paramilitary groups IRA aneta
I found that if you are prepared to
engage with them and try to listen to
them and try to work with them they will
work with you and I'm sure the same is
true of his bola that's a lesson for the
Palestinian situation did you go and
deal with these suicide bombers are
I mean if we're prepared to listen them
and meet them and talk to them you'll
find that we willing to cooperate with
you in terms of what you were trying to
get a peaceful way of solving with them
and I just they're mentioning that as to
how I got involved in that sense of
running into to the tragedy and then I
speak about the lessons of the Irish
peace process and I'll mention them
variant one sentences their self but
there are seven lessons all together I
think and we learned these lessons on
the streets we didn't think the mouth
the first lesson is that you're not
going anywhere without the grace of God
you get into these peacemaking
situations you have mountains of
difficulties and you can see it gosh you
know human resources are not enough here
we just have to depend on divine health
here so that's the first lesson you
leave and the second lesson is the
dignity of the human person that every
array everything that happens every
policy every strategy every agreement
has always to conform to the respect
that is due to the dignity of the human
person that's the vital moral principle
the third lesson is an interesting one
and is from the streets we learnt is
that the most powerful dynamic after the
grace of God that you have the most
powerful human resource is a resource
that comes into operation when the male
and female principles combine their
complementary abilities in dialogue and
consensus in to serve the common good in
other words that means that if you have
some problem of in the common affecting
the common good of society whatever it
might be there is poverty or AIDS or
unemployment or anything if you want to
get the best understanding of that
problem you get it best from a
male-female dialogue about the problem
you get a better on deeper understanding
of the problem from a male/female
dialogue then you will get from a male
dialogue or a female dialogue on their
own if you want to know how to solve the
problem settler if you get a male female
consensus on how to solve this
particular problem
and that consensus will solve the
problem if you put it into a preview
implemented okay so am i I think that's
a bit unusual but it does it does work
on that principle that if you want the
most powerful resource after the grace
of God is the resource that comes into
operation when the male and female
principles combine their respective
abilities in dialogue and consensus in
order to make decisions about the common
good and of course I mean the church
should be set in the lead here but I'm
where the church doesn't give much of a
lead here but I mean that's important
because you see the way translate
translates into this reality that if you
have this world were what were governed
are organized are ruled on the basis of
a male-female dialogue and consensus you
wouldn't have any wouldn't have any
world wars he wouldn't have any words at
all you wouldn't do any sudden masane
you know you wouldn't have a two world
wars in the last century if you go if
you organize the world on the basis of
male/female dialogue and consensus well
that's a big that's a big statement you
know it's all new course that one well
anyways layer on your number three this
is the lesson now this is the lesson the
lesson from the streets this is what the
lesson says that in other words if you
want to remove poverty if you want to
remove age you want to remove any of the
evils of the flick society war violence
then you organize the society on the
basis of male/female dialogue and
consensus and if you do that you'll
emanate all these problems men on their
own are not capable of looking after the
common good of society but neither are
women on their own capable of looking
after the common good style you have to
get them to two of them together and the
church should be doing that you know now
boy yelling huh we got four to go four
minutes is it no well possibly but for
points4 points all got a better
once i say under four more points you
have to make well that was a biblical
seven was it didn't anyway I took for
commissary I'm not helping me anyway but
anyway anyway what I'm trying to say is
and I just want to make the point that
it was almost impossible important point
at issue is that a very any of you will
have to deal with the Hizbollah or these
type of paramilitary organizations the
thing you do is you go and talk to more
the suicide bombers or whatever you want
to deal with them you go and you talk to
them and you listen to them you're
trying to understand them the very fact
you do that will win their respect and
then you from that you'll be able to win
their cooperation but always you have to
be able to say let's get another way the
grating of Gerry Adams language was the
alternatives you had to get an
alternative to the IRA